we wish him all the best our thoughts
will be with him as he grows as an
artist
american idol judges lionel richie luke
bryan and katy perry share their
reactions to contestant caleb kennedy's
shocking departure
the 16 year old former idol hopeful
announced last week that he was leaving
the competition
after a snapchat video resurfaced
reportedly shot when he was 12
showing him next to someone in a white
hood resembling those worn by the kkk
i think viewers were really surprised to
see everything with
caleb and i wondered if you all had any
reaction to that if you'd spoken to him
or had any messages at all for him
well losing great talent is always in
this case this is our class this is the
class of uh
of 2021 so you know it was an
unfortunate situation but
listen we have to ride with what's
happened with abc and you know that's
where we play and so
you know again it's we wish him all the
best but that was just one of those
unfortunate things that
happens along the way of life caleb
apologized for the video in a statement
he shared to instagram
shortly after the clip went viral on
social media
judge luke bryan expressed his
disappointment in the situation
but said he wishes caleb the best
you know we love these kids we love
every aspect
of their growth and their their growth
and all this
and i mean it's a certainly a
devastating
news when we when we hear about this but
like i said i mean
our our thoughts will be with him as he
grows as an artist
meanwhile with caleb out of the
competition sunday's show featured the
final four contestants
vying for a spot in the top three casey
bishop
chase beckham grace kinsler and willie
spence
ultimately sixteen-year-old florida
native casey was eliminated
but the judges are super confident it's
just the beginning for her sure to be
massive career
how hard was it to see casey go casey's
one of my favorites
i think that her song that she just put
out love me or leave me
is one of my favorite songs that's out
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's amazing seeing her growth and
her potential and her stage presence
and i think she's a real mvp i don't
think
you know i don't think it's the end of
the road for her she's not gonna win
american idol but i think she's gonna
win at life mark my words
win the end game the idol judges are
clearly just as close
off screen as they are on katie shared
that her fiance
orlando bloom went for a morning bike
ride with luke earlier in the day
and even shared photographic evidence
there it is oh look at this
he actually actually did it wow hey that
is as much as i can flex my body
flex my muscles in a picture right there
and katie you thought i i got to take a
picture of this i want to remember this
yeah because it was so embarrassing
and i just like the juxtaposition of
like three guys in spandex
oh my god spandex aside
it was a big morning for luke for
another reason
he finally met katie and orlando's
daughter daisy
too it's like the cutest
most precious sweet little nugget
thing i've ever seen ever i mean i was
like
i mean there are i was like she any
minnie katie or minnie orlando right now
it's just the perfect blend right but
her eyeba
her eyes are just so he's so alive
i mean so alive katie was about to call
uh you know
the department of children's services
because i was about to kidnap that girl